[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FOUST: Hi, and
welcome to episode 202
of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Jon Foust, and I'm here with
my colleague and friend, Mark.
Hey, Mark.
How's it going?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hey, Jon.
Always good to see you.
JON FOUST: Well, we can
see each other right now.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, OK.
Well, it is good to see
you now, and always.
JON FOUST: Yes.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And I feel
like the past month has just
been so full of
different activities,
we haven't had much of a
chance to chat until now.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
We also need to find some
time to play some games online
as well.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's
just a bucket of fun
whenever we get
to work together.
JON FOUST: [LAUGHS] On this
episode of the podcast,
we're going to be talking
to Kami May from Supersolid.
They're going to talk about
their new game, "Snake Rivals,"
and how they built it
using Google Cloud.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, it was
really awesome to get a chance
to chat with Kami.
And you wouldn't think
about the amount of work
that needs to go into a
mobile game like this,
because when you think about
it from the mobile perspective,
it's just playing a game.
But there's all these
servers in the back end,
and you have to figure out how
to actually run those, and then
distribute it out based on the
number of players and scale it.
So it's a really, really
great conversation.
JON FOUST: Right.
And it's interesting as
well, because "Snake Rivals"
actually runs on Agones, which
is an open source project.
And that's not something
that a lot of companies
would take the leap
on using, especially
when it's just in its infancy.
I think Kami is going to
mention how early on they
started using Agones
and how engaged
they were in the community.
So it's interesting to
see a studio actually
jump on board with an
open source project
and really run with it and
see how successful they've
become with "Snake Rivals."
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
It was a great conversation.
And I get the feeling that if we
say "Agones" three times fast,
Mark Mandel will appear and give
a tech talk on how he built it.
MARK MANDEL (RECORDED): That
was when I suddenly thought,
what if there was a library
for hosting, running,
and scaling dedicated game
servers on Kubernetes?
What a bonzer idea.
JON FOUST: Right.
[LAUGHS] And then
we're also going
to get into our Question
of the Week, which is,
what are best practices
for setting up
user accounts in Cloud IAM?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I've heard this one
from a lot of people,
especially with relation to some
of the billing content that's
been coming out.
and I think there's some
great best practice tips.
I feel like there's
a good baseline.
We'll link to a quick start
in the show notes, as well.
But it's really
helpful for everyone
just to get a feel for how the
IAM part works of Google Cloud
so that you're able to
make sure that you've
got the right details and
the right access for people.
So we'll go into that
a little bit later.
JON FOUST: Right.
I struggled when I first
joined and I was ramping up
on a bunch of things,
giving myself and others
who want to collaborate
the right privileges
to my projects.
And it was quite
a journey, but I
can say that I'm up there
with the big boys now.
So let's get into our
Cool Things of the Week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So the first thing,
BigQuery has now
had beta support for a
query in Parquet and ROC
file formats in cloud storage.
And these new features
allow you to build
a bridge between your
datasets and help you
be a little bit more flexible.
So your data stays in your
preferred open source formats
in cloud storage and you can
use BigQuery's standard SQL
for analytics and
data processing.
So check the blog post out.
I don't want to ruin too much,
but it's quite interesting.
Parquet.
SPEAKER 1: Butter.
JON FOUST: [LAUGHS]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, I think it's
a great way for people to
have more ways to use BigQuery
without needing to go through
some sort ETL process,
or without having to
change their files.
The more ways you can
ingest and then query
that data, the easier it is,
the better off you'll be.
JON FOUST: Right.
And we've come a
long way from ETL
and I can say that it's
been quite a hassle
dealing with bad datasets.
I was glad to see
additional features being
built onto BigQuery.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
Well, the coolest
thing I found this week
was this fun little
machine learning comic.
I actually-- I have no
idea where it came from.
It just popped up on my radar.
But I actually liked it a lot.
It follows a worker working
for a typically difficult boss,
going down the path
of machine learning.
And then a robot and a cat come
out of nowhere, because well,
why not, and teach her a little
bit about machine learning
and some of the
basic concepts there.
And machine learning
is absolutely very far
from my area of
expertise, so I'm really
excited to read through it.
I'm like, oh, I start to
get these concepts now.
So I'm really excited to
have this comic available.
It'll definitely be
in the show notes,
and I highly recommend it,
even if you're not in that area
whatsoever, just to get a
baseline understanding of what
some of these terms
are about and to see
if it peaks any interest.
And it sounds like they're
going to be coming out
with a second one that
goes more into neural nets.
So I'm sure that'll
be way over my head,
but I'm definitely
looking forward to it.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
I don't think I would put
cats and robots together,
so I'm kind of interested.
I might take a look.
[CAT YOWLS]
[GUNFIRE]
SPEAKER 2 (COMPUTERIZED VOICE):
The human has been neutralized.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, everyone knows
machine learning is only for
identifying pictures of cats,
right?
[LAUGHS]
JON FOUST: And
clouds and cheese.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Ah, yes.
I forgot about cheese.
SPEAKER 3: Don't forget dogs.
JON FOUST: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
And to round things off for
the Cool Things of the Week,
Bitly has actually
migrated to Google Cloud.
So that means you can bring
your own IP addresses to Google
Cloud Network, and you're going
to be able to distribute those
and load balance those
across 20 different regions.
So if you're familiar with
Bitly and all its features,
they're now on Google Cloud.
Go give it a whirl.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I think a lot of people
use Bitly-- well, mainly
for link shortening.
But it's great to be able
to bring your own IP address
and have a lot more
control over that process.
JON FOUST: Exactly.
All right, so now we're going
to be joined by Kami May,
and she's going to tell
us a little bit more
about Supersolid and how they
got started with Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So on this episode,
we're joined today
by Kami May from Supersolid.
Hey, Kami.
How are you doing?
KAMI MAY: I'm good, thank you.
JON FOUST: So Kami, we're
very excited to have you
on the podcast.
I've actually seen
a lot of your work,
and I've heard
quite a bit of you
from a specific Slack
channel that you are part of.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about who you are
and what you do?
KAMI MAY: Sure.
I'm Kami.
I'm Senior Server
Developer at Supersolid.
We are an indie mobile game
studio based in London.
And last week, we launched our
first-ever multiplayer game,
"Snake Rivals."
It's now live on
iTunes and Google Play.
And my biggest role
in this project
was to bring the game online.
And we chose to use
Agones and placed in GCP.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about "Snake Rivals"?
Because both Mark
and I are very big
gamers, so we would love
to hear more about it.
KAMI MAY: It's a
session-based game.
So you go into the
arena and you have
three modes to choose from.
There is Endless, where you
just play until you get bored.
The goal is to get
the longest snake.
There is Gold Rush, where the
goal is to kill as many snakes
as you can in three minutes.
And there is Battle Royale.
That is a very
self-explanatory mode.
[LAUGHTER]
It's basically like
"Slither.io," but on steroids.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it's
that classic snake game
that I think most people
probably remember, possibly--
KAMI MAY: Yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: --from
their old cell phones,
but now taken up a
notch with multiplayer.
KAMI MAY: In 3D graphics.
JON FOUST: I can imagine with
these specific game modes,
especially with a
Battle Royale mode,
there's probably a need for
a very, very massive scale.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about how you got up to
date in running with Agones?
KAMI MAY: Sure.
So when we planned this
game, we didn't really
have any experience on how
to solve the online problems,
because we have never made
a multiplayer game before.
And so we looked
into a few options.
We did a lot of research.
And we stuck that Kubernetes
must be the way to go,
because in terms of price
and resource management,
it would cost the least
to do what we need.
And we looked into a
few options on where
to go with the Kubernetes,
and we found Agones project.
At that time, it
was extremely early
in the development process.
It was in August 2018.
But we decided to
give it a go anyways,
because we have
such a small team.
It was only two
server developers
working on this game.
One of them was purely
a game server developer,
so he didn't do
any sort of DevOps.
And then there was me, who
had to figure it all out.
And there was really no time
for me to write everything
and launch the game in a year.
So due to lack of
resources, we decided
to give a go to
Agones, even if it
was alpha project at that time.
We tried it and
it worked for us.
It worked very well,
and we stuck with it.
And it launched 0.1 just as we
launched our game, so that's
extremely good timing.
So we went into
production as Agones
was released in full release
rather than any sort of beta.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Which is just
amazing timing, first of all.
KAMI MAY: Yes, it was.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But obviously,
if Mark Mandel were here,
he could explain Agones.
And I'm sure several of
our podcast listeners
have heard it before.
Let's give a basic
rundown for people
who may not have heard of it.
What did Agones do that
was different from just
running Kubernetes by itself?
KAMI MAY: OK.
So Agones is a custom
resource on top of Kubernetes,
and it has very basic
functionality that
is absolutely required
for game servers,
such as server
allocation and not
killing allocated servers that
already having players on it.
So even if you roll out
the update in mid-session,
players that are
already in session
should never lose their
progress at that time.
So it had simple allocation.
It had ability to scale,
even though it was not
at first in Agones when
we started using it,
and I had to write
custom code to do that.
But in further releases,
they added those features.
And there is also ability
to scale during live.
So let's say we suddenly have
a massive surge in players.
We can simply change the buffer,
deploy, and with no downtime,
we have a lot more
available servers.
It also has a way
to add labels, so we
know what's going on in
that particular game mode.
It has different fleets, so
you can have different game
modes in different fleets.
So for example, our
game server code
is the same code for all modes.
We just add different
variables to set environment
for different game mode.
So all those features
were crucial for our game.
And without Agones, I would
have to write it all myself
JON FOUST: Awesome.
So it sounds like there
were things that were hard,
especially when you first
started using Agones,
because it was only 0.1.
So I can imagine that there
were some things that were hard,
and some things that
were really easy.
So can you tell us
a little bit more
about what you found
very hard dealing with,
and what you found
very, very simple?
KAMI MAY: So I guess
difficulties were the bugs.
[LAUGHTER]
So I guess when you
start using software,
you are aware that
it is alpha release.
But because you're so
brand-new to this whole scene,
you are unsure
whether it's a bug
or whether it works as expected.
There were a lot of
conversations in Slack
where I would bring
it all up, and I was
able to find quite a few bugs.
I think it was also because
we went into production
with Agones very early on
and we found a lot of things
that otherwise
simulated scenarios
wouldn't be able to catch.
There was a bug where,
if the pod shut down,
the game server would remain.
And so the game server
would not point to any pod.
So those things were quite
difficult to deal with.
A lot of manual
work had to be done.
And I guess the easy part
was literally the rest.
It was just very easy, even if
you have no previous experience
using Kubernetes.
If you have some server
engineering knowledge,
it will be quite
straightforward.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah,
because you mentioned
that you were coming into this
with one other game server
engineer.
And between the two
of you, you didn't
have a lot of
familiarity with-- sounds
like even Kubernetes itself.
KAMI MAY: No, we didn't use
Kubernetes at all before.
All we used was
Heroku, actually.
Our previous games are
very single-player type
of games where you
have some validation
and it just needs to
have an HTTP server that
validates your actions.
In this case, we need a
TCP connection, validate
all the movements
of the players,
and this all has to be
separate servers for each game.
So this was something that
we didn't really do before.
We had some guidance
from Google once we
decided to go with Google,
and that was very helpful.
We had some courses given to us.
They gave us some credits to
view the Google University
type of thing, and that
was all very useful.
JON FOUST: That's awesome.
I can hear a lot of
troubleshooting coming
from Google, but I'm curious.
Working with Agones in
an open source manner--
I know that you're
a part of the Slack,
because I'm also a
part of that Slack,
and I know how quite frequently
you post in that Slack,
so I'm pretty sure you and Mark
are really good best friends.
But can you tell us
a little bit more
about how it is dealing with a
gaming solution in open source?
KAMI MAY: I did have to
go through a lot of logs
in Agones sidecars to
find out what's going on--
when it is our fault, when it
is Agones doing something funny.
And I found that when
we got to the point
where we had to really
dig into the logs,
they were written so well
and so descriptively,
it would literally point to
the issue almost straightaway.
So that was extremely useful.
There's some times
that you're not
quite sure what you
can do about the issue,
and you go through
Agones' source code,
even though I've never
written a line in Go.
I just look through
the source code
to find where the
code is coming from,
where is this error
coming from, to try
and figure out what
is going wrong.
And I think it being open
source really helped,
because I could really
find where the issue is
coming from sometimes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So obviously, you
were using Agones from when
it was still in testing phase.
And it sounds like there was
a lot of active communication
between you, Mark, and other
people working on it, which
is actually pretty cool, right?
Sometimes you get to work
on an open source platform
and you can make
some pull requests
and those sorts of things.
But it sounds like there was
a really active communication
channel.
How did that affect
your launch window?
When you've got a
deadline, game developers
often have a big
rush, especially
towards the end when they're
trying to get ready to launch.
How is that communication?
Did it help you, obviously,
in launching the game?
KAMI MAY: Yeah, I think so.
Actually, we had a lot of
calls ongoing in the year.
We had meetings last year
with Google and Mark,
and we also had some third party
coming in, assessing our setup,
to tell us whether or not
we're production ready.
They looked at our setup.
They said it was very good--
[LAUGHS] especially
considering the team size.
There were some
really good pointers,
so there were difficult
questions we had to ask,
because we really didn't
know which direction to take.
And the example is a
global load balancer.
How do you load balance six
different regions under one IP?
Those things, we
were not aware of.
And asking Google really helped
us to come with solutions.
And we already had deadlines
set quite a long time ago
that was not
relevant to the help.
So we had a deadline that
was promised by our CEO
to Google and Apple,
and we had to deliver.
And I guess there was
one hiccup that we had,
which was quite unpleasant,
is that our quota increase was
really delayed.
And we were quite
unsure whether or not
we would get enough
quota in time for launch.
However, once we emailed
our account manager,
that was all done so quickly.
[LAUGHS] So I think it's
just reaching out to people
at the right time is the key.
And Google is extremely
helpful at that.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
So it sounds like
there were a couple
of things that seemed to start
to get to you towards launch.
So I'm curious.
What happens post-launch?
What happens when your game's
running and everything looks
really well, but there
needs to be a plan?
I know Agones scales
very well, but there
needs to be a plan for any
type of server improvements
that can happen post-launch.
So can you tell us a
little bit about that?
KAMI MAY: Yeah, sure.
So our further plan is
actually-- currently,
we have nine clusters, so we're
live in nine different regions
for now.
We'll Google assess in the
future and remove some of them
if they have no load.
So currently, each region
is very independent,
and they all have
all the services
running in each region.
However, that's not
very cost-efficient,
and some services are
not very time-sensitive.
So we want to move all of
those into the central cluster,
probably in the US East region,
and save money on resources.
But also to improve updating.
So right now, deployments
are quite elaborate.
We have to deploy
to each region.
And we would want to make
minimal changes to each region.
And having it all centralized
would make it a lot easier.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well ultimately,
it's like a trade-off, right?
It's a trade-off between
being able to have
these regions closer
to the people who
are playing the game versus the
complexity of the deployment
pipeline.
But in the case of actually
playing a game, especially
a networked game,
it's always going
to be to minimize the latency
for those players, right?
KAMI MAY: Yes.
So game servers will most
definitely remain in all
the regions that we want to
provide the non-sensitive data,
like just validating when
you change your name--
saving your preferences.
This doesn't require
immediate response,
so it's fine if it
has a bit of latency.
JON FOUST: So I'm curious.
How do you actually
measure exactly where
you want it to locate?
KAMI MAY: So this was a--
[LAUGHS] big problem.
We were looking
at the map and we
were looking at what
zones does Google provide,
and really thinking
what we want to do.
So for launch, we really wanted
minimal latency for everyone
around the world.
So we went above and beyond and
created nine different regions.
Once we have more
data, once we know
what ping is where, we
can assess and decide.
Maybe some regions are
not really required.
Because in Asia, we have
three different regions.
That seems a bit of an overkill.
So for now, we have nine.
And we decided it just
by looking at the map
and thinking what latency would
be effective for everyone.
Because this game can't hold
more than 150ms latency.
Post that, it gets hard to play.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So that
means there's probably
a lot of work going into
the data collection of users
playing the game and
understanding what kind
of metrics you can
measure on them.
Can you talk a little bit
more about getting information
from the players that
have played since launch?
KAMI MAY: Well, all of this
data is coming from the client,
so we have a lot of
data analytics going
into our BigQuery.
I'm not a data analyst,
but our all data analytics
is also on Google.
And we have Looker dashboards
that we can check every day,
so that's one of the things
we usually do every morning.
We open the Looker here
and look what went wrong,
and hope nothing did.
So all of the analytics
comes from actual client.
We sometimes get some
feedback from players,
but it's usually less
useful, because we
need to know exactly what
happened for that case.
JON FOUST: So I
could imagine that
dealing with a lot of
servers-- and there
has to be a lot of logs that
you have to deal with, as well.
So I'm not sure if you're using
any Google products for that.
How do you trace the
logs for anything
that can possibly go wrong
with any of your users?
KAMI MAY: Google has
amazing log tool.
This was so good--
life saving.
It makes searching for
particular logs extremely easy.
Obviously we had to
put some work into it.
We had to make sure that our
logs print out the data that
would be useful for debugging.
So we had many
iterations of releases
to know, oh, we are trying
to deal with this issue
but we are missing this data.
So we keep adding, to the point
where in production now, we
are more or less confident
if something goes wrong,
we can find what happened
to you because we
have sufficient logging.
And Stackdriver makes
it so easy to find it.
It's so useful.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, it sounds
like you've gotten
a lot of advantage
out of using the Google Cloud
ecosystem as a whole, right?
You mentioned BigQuery,
Stackdriver, and then
of course, Agones on Kubernetes.
Are there any things
that you've run
into that you feel
like we're missing,
or things that you feel
like would have helped you
along that way faster?
KAMI MAY: I guess there are
some things that are there
but are harder to set up.
So like, I'm really not a
professional here with VPCs
or load balancing stuff.
And I have to use
such as kubemci
to set up global load
balancing across clusters
and further dig into it
to add some HTTPS security
certificates on top of that.
And all of these things
are quite difficult and--
[LAUGHS] high level to me.
So I guess all the
documentation that I
found on the website
was extremely
useful to get myself going, but
you can't make things easier.
It seemed to be
quite good so far.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
Happy to take "everything is
perfect and awesome" answer.
JON FOUST: So Supersolid-- can
you tell us a little bit more
where you guys are located?
And any plans for
the near future?
Because I know Agones has
been really great for you,
both in production
and open source.
But I could imagine
that Supersolid probably
has a lot more plans,
and I could imagine--
if you want to talk about
that, any other plans
for any large scale, massive
multiplayer games, as well?
KAMI MAY: Yeah, so Supersolid
does have a few games in mind,
and they have been in prototype
and soon to be in production.
However, to my
disappointment, they're
not massive multiplayer games.
JON FOUST: OK.
KAMI MAY: Unfortunately, I won't
get to bring any multiplayer
games online soon.
But maybe in the near
future, as it was.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I'm right here.
I'm downloading "Snake Rivals"
right now so I can play it.
Why not just add an MMO version
of "Snake Rivals," right?
You've already
got Battle Royale.
So now just create an
open world concept,
have the snakes roam around,
level up by, I assume,
eating apples, collecting coins.
I'm telling you, that was
a great pitch right there.
KAMI MAY: I'm not
a game designer.
I don't get to have a say.
I just bring games online.
JON FOUST: I actually
have a surprise.
I pinged Mark in chat, and
he told me to tell you hi.
KAMI MAY: Hi, Mark.
SPEAKER 1: Hello, there.
Sorry I couldn't make it, but
I'm quite busy with Agones.
JON FOUST: [LAUGHS]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
I know a lot of people
get confused about the
two Marks on the podcast.
SPEAKER 1: Honestly,
I'm shocked by that.
The two of us don't
sound anything alike.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I would love
to have a two Mark's podcast.
Maybe that'll be our successor.
Mark and I can go spin
off a separate one.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks
for the notion.
I love it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: But I
got a ping from somebody
saying how
disappointed they were
when I was leaving the podcast.
And I said, well, that's nice.
Unfortunately, it's
the other Mark.
JON FOUST: [LAUGHS]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It still felt
nice to me for someone to say,
so I'll take it.
JON FOUST: Were you
always in the gaming
space when it came to being
a senior server engineer?
KAMI MAY: So I
graduated in 2015,
and my first job
was in telecoms.
That was quite unrelated
to what I do now.
That was more like
analyzing data.
But as soon as I
got an opportunity
to join the game
industry, I just took it.
In early 2016, that's when
I start working in games.
JON FOUST: That's
a really big shift
from going from
telecoms to games.
I would assume that you really
wanted to be in the space.
You are probably
a gamer as well?
KAMI MAY: Yes, very much so.
So I like to spend most
of my free time playing
video games, in particular PC--
PC Master Race.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
JON FOUST: OK.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
As a representative
of the console sub-race, I will
always feel more comfortable
with a controller in my hands.
KAMI MAY: I do have a Switch.
That's the only console I have.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
The Switch is nice.
It's a lot of fun and
it's easy to move around.
And I think that if you
see a lot of mobile games,
you can feel like this, plus
a lot of extra features,
could make a really
fun Switch game.
KAMI MAY: Yes, definitely.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
when is "Snakes Rivals"
coming to Switch?
KAMI MAY: Oh, man.
[LAUGHTER]
Unfortunately, I think
the answer is never.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, all right.
Well, maybe the next game.
JON FOUST: I'm with
you on the PC side.
So I'm curious.
What games are you
really interested in?
I can see you shaking
your head, Mark.
I'm sorry, man.
[LAUGHS]
KAMI MAY: I guess the game that
I spend a lot of time playing
recently is "Path of Exile."
so every league, I clock in
about 50 hours a week on top
of my full-time job, and--
JON FOUST: Nice.
KAMI MAY: I guess I
really like "Tetris."
That's probably one
of the only games
that I'm extremely good at,
so that's on the Switch.
What else?
I do like "Dota."
However, I haven't
played recently.
It's been a lost love.
I've spent 3,000
hours playing it.
It's burnt out at this point.
JON FOUST: [LAUGHS]
KAMI MAY: And yeah, anything
that comes out and is great,
like "GreedFall."
I'm really excited to
play "Outer Worlds."
Is that the one?
So yeah, I'm a bit
of a mixed bag.
Everything that's good,
I'm going to play it.
JON FOUST: That's great.
Mark and I compete locally
and smash all the time.
I'm more of a competitive
first-person shooter type
person.
So you just might see me playing
like "Overwatch" or "Call
of Duty."
And as far as
MMOs, I've probably
played "Final Fantasy XIV."
So I'm curious.
Being a gamer, did
that really inspire
you to get into the space?
Because like I said, it's
a very, very big shift
from telecoms.
KAMI MAY: Since I
was 14, I knew I was
going to be programming games.
I was useless at art or
anything else, really.
So I thought, I'll
just do programming.
It's great.
Anyone can do programming.
So since I was 14, that
was always something
that I knew I'm going to do.
That here I am.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, I think there's
a lot of people who,
they feel like they
want to be in the gaming world.
It actually turns out
it's very competitive.
It's a very challenging
space to be.
So there's a lot
of work that goes
into getting in and
staying in that industry.
KAMI MAY: I think it
is a job of passion.
For example, server engineers
are very hard to come by.
And a few of our coworkers
that are server engineers
are not from the
gaming industry.
They don't play video
games or any sort of games,
but they're just
good at programming.
I guess it depends.
Maybe there is more competition
in art or in maybe production.
But in programming, please come.
[LAUGHS] Please
come, programmers.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, it's
probably good call to action,
that Supersolid's
probably hiring, right?
KAMI MAY: Yes, we are.
So any game programmers or
server developers, hit us up.
Go to supersolid.com or to
the jobs page in London.
And if you're interested, apply.
We're a good place to be.
JON FOUST: Yeah.
I enjoy coming to London
all the time, so--
I should actually be coming
back to London early next year.
So maybe we can sync
up and have some lunch.
Maybe you can recommend
some good places for me.
KAMI MAY: Sure, I can.
JON FOUST: I'm really looking
forward to seeing Supersolid,
probably at any upcoming game
conferences like GDC or PAX's.
So it was really fun to
see you guys mentioned,
because that's where I first
heard of "Snake Rivals."
KAMI MAY: Yeah, our
CEO was doing a talk.
And he had us prepare
him all the information.
So it was very nice to see him
actually talk and understand
what's going on
behind the scenes.
JON FOUST: Yeah,
I'm pretty sure it's
pretty rough to ramp your CEO
up in all the technical details
for a gaming conference.
[LAUGHS]
KAMI MAY: He did very well.
I was impressed.
JON FOUST: Yeah, he did.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh,
and then, of course,
people can download "Snake
Rivals" on iOS and Android.
KAMI MAY: Yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And of course, they
can find it on the
Supersolid website.
Are there any other
ways that people
can see what Supersolid's
doing and what's upcoming?
KAMI MAY: Yeah, just visit our
website or find us on Twitter
@supersolid.
And please play our
"Snake Rivals" game.
If you find any bugs, don't
forget to leave some feedback,
and we will make
sure we address it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: The
first step, of course,
is to figure out if it's a
Supersolid bug or an Agones
bug.
KAMI MAY: Yes, that's
very important.
SPEAKER 1: $50 says
it's Supersolid.
[LAUGHTER]
JON FOUST: Yeah, so we'll
be sure to link a Supersolid
both on iOS and Android
in our show notes
for all of our listeners.
So Kami, it's been an
absolute pleasure having you
on this episode, and we look
forward to hearing from you
and Supersolid in
the near future.
KAMI MAY: Thank you very much.
JON FOUST: Well,
thank you, Kami,
for joining us on this episode.
It's really great to see the
adaption of open source gaming
projects and games.
And also, it's really
interesting to see the journey
that Kami and Supersolid has
taken with "Snake Rivals."
Starting with Agones
from its early stages,
0.4 release to almost
manage release.
So it's great to see
that full journey
and how they've been utilizing
all of our Google Cloud
Platform tools to
actually help keep
their game very successful.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
It was really great to
see exactly how easy
it was for them to use Agones.
But also, how involved
they were in helping
ping out these issues.
I really liked what
Kami said about,
she had never touched a
Go in her life before,
but everything was
well-written enough
and easy to understand
enough that she
was able to jump in and find
out what was going wrong.
And so that just speaks to a
really, really cool open source
project.
And it sounds like hopefully,
as Agones moves down the road,
there'll be plenty
more case studies
of other people having really
great experiences with it.
JON FOUST: So
we're going to jump
into our Question of the Week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What are the best
practices for setting up
user accounts in Cloud IAM?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, there is
definitely a tremendous amount
of best practices.
But I think it's also
important for everyone,
no matter what kind of role
you're using Google Cloud
Platform in, to get at least a
baseline understanding of Cloud
IAM.
So I'll link to a quick start
guide and to a checklist guide,
but some of the bigger ones
that I've seen come up recently
are--
of course, Cloud recommends
this least-privilege principle.
And this is the idea
that you're only
giving people exactly the
permissions that they need,
and no more.
Typically, this is done
just to prevent mistakes
from happening, right?
If you've got
someone who is going
to be working in a
development environment,
you want to give them
the right permissions
for that development
environment.
But you also want to
make sure that they only
have permissions they need, such
as spinning up Compute Engine
instances, rather than
spinning up some other products
that you don't plan on using.
That could be really
important when
you're in a large
organization, because it'll
be really hard to track down if
someone accidentally spits up
something very expensive.
And then you don't realize
it until way down the road,
and you've got this
big bill to pay
because of just a simple error.
So it's always really important
to be very thoughtful about it,
and that's why Cloud IAM also
lets you create custom roles.
So I know we've all been in that
boat where we're just like, OK.
Someone needs to
get something done.
Let's just give them
project owner role,
and then they'll
just take care of it.
But that's really not--
[LAUGHS] that's really not
the best way to do things,
because you can easily get
yourself into trouble with just
having someone, even if--
it's usually just
by accident-- having
some accidental resources
spin up or something shut off.
So I recommend creating
custom roles for that.
And on top of that, you're
also able to assign roles
to groups rather than users.
And this falls under this
idea of reasonable redundancy,
where if you have someone who
is responsible for some very
important thing on some
very important project,
and then that person is no
longer around for some reason,
or isn't available, you're
going to be in a lot of trouble
if that person has that
task they need to do.
So a big example
for finance teams
is making sure that you have
a billing administrator,
because there are some
things only a billing
administrator can do.
So a great example for that
is, instead of assigning it
to a user, assign it to a group.
And in G Suite, you
can have a group
or you can have
groups in other ways.
And once you have a group, you
can then add and remove people
from that group as your staffs
or your employee might change,
so that you're not
having to update
that role every single time.
You can just have this
trusted pool of users.
This can give you
an easy way to have
that reasonable level of
redundancy in case someone
isn't available, without
having to go in and edit IAM
all the time.
So we'll link to those in
the checklist in the notes.
I think they're really
great for people to review,
and I definitely
recommend people
going to check out
the IAM interface
and playing around
with it, just to get
a quick feel of
how the roles work
and maybe creating
a custom role.
So that in the
future, when they get
into larger and more
complex scenarios,
you'll have a
better understanding
of what are the best
principles to enact there
when you're adding them.
JON FOUST: Awesome.
I've actually played
around with custom roles,
and it's actually
what I use as a go-to
when I am asking someone to
work on something, whether it's
internal or external,
and I want them to only
be able to use, for example,
like a service account.
So I assign a role
to a service account
and give them privilege and use
of that hard, actual service
account-- the JSON file
you actually download.
And they can use that
freely for whatever purposes
that I give them.
And it's really good, because
when I'm doing game demos,
it's really good to allow
them to access and make
any type of request
that you would normally
do with an account
owner, or any small demo
that you're working with.
And only given them the
privileges that they need.
That means that it's just
read and write privileges,
and that's just about it.
So custom roles has definitely
been a powerful feature
that I've utilized,
and I definitely
recommend our listeners
to take a good look at it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We'll
make sure to include
a link for service accounts
as well, because that's
something I didn't mention.
But that is another
kind of best practices.
If you're talking about having
a human go in and do things,
you're going to typically give
it to that user's account.
But if you want to
have them call an API
or work from a
machine or in code,
you actually want to
use a service account,
because then you have even
more control over that access.
So a couple of helpful
references for people
who are interested in that.
But if you don't want
to read all that,
my recommendation is
just go to the IAM pages
and play around with them
and get a feel for how it is.
JON FOUST: So Mark, where
are you going to be?
Are you traveling
anywhere, or have you
even finished traveling?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, I
am finished traveling.
I think by the time
this episode airs,
I'll be landing from
a quick trip to Austin
to work with some
customers out there.
But then after that, I am
going to try and remain
in the city of San Francisco
for as long as possible.
We'll see if I make it
beyond a couple of days.
But generally
speaking, I'm going
to try and stay local and just
work on some cool new content
that I've been planning out
for the past few months.
What about you, Jon?
JON FOUST: Oh,
for me, I am going
to be attending Anime NYC--
[GONG STRIKES]
--which is going
to be pretty fun.
I last year for the first time.
It's really good
is just hang out
with people who just want
to have a really good time.
And overall, just fans of anime.
And next month, I'll
actually be at KubeCon
working on the Agones and Open
Match workshop in San Diego.
Afterwards, I'll be in
Kirkland for an internal
Hack Week, which will
be fun, because we're
working on a bunch of
things for Open Match,
and it's really good
to just sit down
with the dev team
and just really,
really, really just get
into it and just build
whatever wacky thing we can
come up with and see if we can
find any bugs or anything, so--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It sounds
like a lot of fun trips.
JON FOUST: Yeah, definitely.
[LAUGHS] So that's
going to do it for us
on this episode of the podcast.
We would like to thank
you all for listening,
and we would like for
you to tune in next week.
Have a good one, Mark.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right.
We'll see you, Jon.
And see you, everybody.
SPEAKER 1: All right, kids.
Catch you later.
[THEME MUSIC]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, you
get these new superheroes,
like Daredevil and
Green Arrow that like--
they just wear
tights, and then they
get their own
drama-filled TV shows.
It's all dark superhero,
you know what I mean?
JON FOUST: Yeah.
But why does Hawkeye--
why is he a superhero?
He just has really good aim.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's-- he's
just a mean dude who has really
good aim.
That's exactly-- well, same
thing with Black Widow, right?
JON FOUST: Yes.
She has utilities.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well--
JON FOUST: Well,
technically, they both do.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
The proof there, Jon,
is that being a superhero isn't
about the powers you have.
It's about what's in your heart.
JON FOUST: [LAUGHS]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So if
you believe you're a hero,
you can be a superhero.
JON FOUST: I'm laughing because
Batman doesn't believe--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: No.
JON FOUST: And he--
he just--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
That's the third
kind of superhero,
is if you're a rich [BLEEP],,
you can also be a superhero.